jamie lee curtis loves a costume party
she had everyone dress up for last
night's halloween kills premiere
including me but jamie let's just say
she went a little psycho
i'm honoring my beautiful late mama
janet lee but i'm actually it's a little
more meta than that
i'm actually going as scarlett johansson
as janet lee
in the movie hitchcock so it's meta and
mommy
did a little diy
uh
art project the other day i thought
you know
maybe i need a
little bloody shower curtain
okay you're just killing me you're
killing me
thank you
um
i wanted your nuts
i lost them a long time ago i think okay
well i don't know one single actress who
didn't want to be annie hall so i'm like
living out a fantasy
open your mouth let me check ah
my wife and i were bonnie and clyde uh
it was the first costume i saw trashy
lingerie and i didn't have a lot of time
kyle richards circus look yeah it seems
fitting since tonight's the night we get
to see the real housewives of beverly
hills explosive reunion three words
terrifying
exhausting
um
oh my god
frightening
there's some tears let's put it this way
put your seat belts on who believes
erica did not know anything about what
tom was doing i feel like erica in the
hot seat i don't know how it's going to
go for her she addressed all the
questions that she was asked it was
again the most difficult reunion for her
absolutely it was very uncomfortable at
times trust me kyle was super
comfortable returning to the halloween
franchise though 43 years after she was
in the original the latest thriller hits
theaters and streams on peacock this
friday michael
michael what has it been like
being the face of this franchise for so
long
thank you
so much matt cohen with et
here with michael myers my squirrel
outfit
[Music]